foreign
[Music]
briefing for Monday November 14th I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
in recent weeks lots of big tech
companies have announced massive layoffs
on Wednesday Mark Zuckerberg apologized
to workers for 11
000 planned job cuts at meta lift stripe
and of course Twitter have also
announced Cuts some big tech companies
have also announced other belt
tightening measures as well
it's a big come down for an industry
that's not only seen huge growth over
the last few years but whose workers
have become accustomed to lots of perks
as part of the job joining us to discuss
the changes and the mood they're leading
to among Tech workers is wsj reporter
chip cutter who covers workplace
management and Leadership hi chip thanks
for joining me hi there thanks for
having me can you start by telling us a
little bit about these perks I mean take
us through what some of the common ones
were and maybe what some of the more
lavish ones were well just take earlier
this year when Google welcomed employees
back to its offices in Silicon Valley
lizzo performed I mean there was a
concert for employees at meta the parent
to Facebook and Instagram there was once
free laundry service and so you know
Tech employees for a long time have
enjoyed really above Market pay plenty
of equity lots of free food on campuses
and all sorts of perks designed to just
make them do their jobs in the most
productive way possible to give them
what they need so they can focus on work
and we're starting to see a real shift
here companies are getting more cautious
about spending they're emphasizing that
workers need to be more productive and
there's a real mood shift across Silicon
Valley you know so we are seeing all of
these announcements about layoffs what
kinds of workers though are actually
losing their jobs
well it really varies and so there have
been some engineers and others who have
lost their jobs but what we've seen so
far it's been a lot of employees who
might be in more call them
administrative roles you know they might
be doing marketing for example or in
finance whatever it might be I mean it
really ranges but Tech recruiters have
been telling us that it's typically
those with technical Talent like
Engineers like data scientists are
probably a little safer than those who
might feel more corporate functions
I mean given how many people are losing
their jobs are there enough places for
them to go well the job market has
remained really tight this has been an
economy that has where a lot of
companies have been looking for
technical talent for a long time so
there are plenty of big companies that
still would like to hire from Big Tech
but we've heard from recruiters and
others that you know there may not be
enough startups for example that could
absorb all of these employees in the
market that it may be a little bit more
difficult and so I think it sort of
depends what happens over the next
couple of months but this is a job
market that is changing even though
plenty of places would be happy to add
additional Engineers would be happy to
have program managers and data
scientists and others in their companies
and so what I think this is doing is
causing some people in Tech to look
elsewhere for roles we've been hearing
that some are considering perhaps
industries that seem a little more
stable like financial services for
example or something like logistics
companies that may not have been on
people's radar before but now now might
be appealing in part because they still
offer High cash pay but they also maybe
offer a little more stability right now
workers are going to
feel being at the jobs because you
mentioned they might have equivalent pay
but the perks that was always a tech
thing yeah I mean the perks may be a
little bit different one company I spoke
with it's citizens Financial it's a
regional bank and the Chief Information
officer there told me that you know we
offer stability we offer meaningful work
we have interesting projects we do not
offer ping pong tables or Nitro cold
brew so there'd be an adjustment there
and but I think people throughout the
pandemic have reassessed their careers
what they want from them and they want
oftentimes more flexibility they want
careers they can feel good about so this
is all coming at an interesting time
we'll have to see sort of how workers
decide where to go next as they sort of
assess what's happening in Tech right
now and where they want to go people
aren't just jumping in for the Nitro
cold brew anymore I guess as nice as
that is as much as everybody loves cold
brew it's uh there's maybe more to
consider I mean let's talk a little bit
more about that mood obviously layoffs
don't make anyone happy but what kind of
reactions are we seeing from the people
who are losing their jobs well there's
real sadness out there I mean you see
this in Anonymous posts on the network
blind people just saying this is just
the start of what might be more to come
you see on social media networks like
LinkedIn people offering help to those
who've been laid off there have been
layoff lists distributed so a lot of
people are trying to help in this moment
and recruiters say they've also noticed
a shift where recruiters who for years
were trying to get on the radar of tech
Talent were trying to convince them to
be you know interested in certain
opportunities they now say that they're
seeing a real Spike an inbound requests
from Tech workers what about the mood of
the people who aren't being let go and
are still at these big Tech companies
well that's always a real issue I mean
it's those who remain sometimes feel
that sort of survivor's guilt where they
now are forced to manage teams or
operate within teams that have fewer
people perhaps there's questions about
why some were laid off and others remain
it can take a real toll on morale inside
companies and I think that's a real
issue that managers and Executives and
others will have to think through
because after a layoff like projects do
change projects might have to be
redistributed to other workers it's all
a lot to take in and you've seen that
already after a number of the big
layoffs where workers are just saying it
feels sad inside some of these companies
what about those perks for the people
who remain at the big tech companies I
mean the Nitro cold brew the free
laundry are these things still
incentivizing them to stay at the big
tech companies well I think a lot of
tech workers would say you know they're
at these companies primarily because
they feel like they're doing interesting
work and they feel like they're doing
projects that help them grow and of
course they are compensated for that
depend a and the stock all of that is
typically above what they might make in
other Industries and so I think a lot of
people want to remain in tech for these
reasons I think many are then just
trying to figure out where in Tech makes
sense are there places where you could
sort of work for the moment that feel a
little more stable than others
how are those being affected by the
layoffs tech stocks are way down
people's net worth is tied up in the
equity that they have in their company
and so a lot of tech workers have said
they now are reassessing whether they
want to take vacations whether they want
to perhaps sell a car whatever it might
mean so this does have an effect and
what's interesting too is that some
Venture Capital firms are advising
employers to try to conserve cash as
much as possible and so that might mean
not raising salaries as much in the
future or trying to kind of keep pay
flat I think there are real questions
about how people sort of fare in all
this all right that's our reporter chip
cutter thanks for joining us chip you're
welcome thanks for having me and that's
it for today's Tech news briefing if you
want more Tech stories check out our
website I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]